uno de los peores desastres ecológicos
de la historia reciente de perú la
erupción del volcán submarino de tonga a
10.000 kilómetros dejó graves
consecuencias al menos 18 mil kilómetros
cuadrados se han visto afectados por el
derrame de 6.000 barriles de petróleo en
el norte de lima y en la región de
callao las grandes olas afectaron a un
buque italiano que estaba cargando fuel
en la refinería de la pampilla la
cancillería de perú señala como
responsable a la petrolera española
repsol el derrame de petróleo de repsol
en ventanilla es el peor desastre
ecológico ocurrido en lima en los
últimos tiempos y ha ocasionado un grave
perjuicio a cientos de familias de
pescadores repsol debe resarcir este año
de manera inmediata
se habrían visto afectadas siete
asociaciones de pescadores
decenas se concentraron en las
instalaciones de la región de callado
junto a la capital de lima para exigir
recompensas lo que queremos que
reconozca que los daños que han cometido
ellos en nuestro fuente de trabajo o sea
que tienen que nos tenéis que dar
repsol niega su responsabilidad y
asegura que están realizando tareas de
limpieza mientras se apuntan que a
diferencia de ecuador y chile la marina
peruana no avisó de la posibilidad de
tsunami pero el daño además de económico
y para el sector de la pesca ha afectado
a la fauna especialmente a aves habría
causado un gran impacto no solamente al
elemento agua sino a todos los seres
vivos que hay sobre este elemento agua y
el suelo de las playas son las
consecuencias del volcán de tonga que
también dejaron el fallecimiento de dos
mujeres el sábado pero pasan los días y
el mar sigue estando negro